اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح اهلا بكم وسط
معارك في شمال وجنوب القطاع جيش الاحتلال
يعلن مقتل جندي واصابه اخرين في وقت اعلنت
فيه كتائب القسام قصف تجمعات لقوات
اسرائيليه ونشرت سرايا القدس صورا لقصف
اليات في حين قال قاده عسكريون اسرائيليون
ان هدف تدمير حماس لم يتحقق اتساع نطاق
الخلافات في دائره صنع القرار في اسرائيل
وسائل اعلام تحدثت عن عراك اثر محاوله
وزير الدفاع اقتحام مكتب نتنياهو وتهديده
بجلب قوات جولاني للسيطره على الوضع هذا
وقد نشرت كتائب القسام رساله موجهه
لعائلات الاسرى تحذرهم من كذب الحكومه
ونفاد الوقت قصف اسرائيلي مكثف على احياء
سكنيه في القطاع ووزاره الصحه تعلن
استشهاد
178 فلسط ينيا خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
وفي الضفه الغربيه فجرت قوات الاحتلال
منزلي شهيدين في مدينه الخليل قبل
انسحابها منها وتعتقل 15 فلسطينيا في
مناطق ع وعلى الجبهه الشماليه حزب الله
يقصف بالصواريخ سكنه برانيت في الجليل
الغربي بينما استهدفت غاره اسرائيليه
سياره في بلده كفره جنوب لبنان وشنت
مقاتلات اسرائيليه غارتين على بلده مركبه
وسط قصف مدفعي على محيط بلده اخرى الى
اللقاء